en este vídeo vamos a ver cómo dibujar
las estructuras de puntos de lewis de
las moléculas orgánicas simples que
tienen únicamente enlaces simples si me
fijo en la fórmula molecular ch4 que es
la fórmula del metano y quiero dibujar
la estructura de puntos de louis de esta
molécula lo que haría sería tomar mi
tabla periódica orgánica y encontrar en
ella al carbono fijarme en qué grupo
está y podemos ver que está en el grupo
4 y por lo tanto el carbono tiene 4
electrones de valencia o sea que hace 4
enlaces y así es como se como dibujar al
carbono aunque tenemos aquí el carbono y
lo dibujo con sus 4 electrones de
valencia hay que recordar de lo que
sabemos de química general que los
electrones de valencia son los que están
en los mayores niveles de energía ok en
los niveles de energía exteriores
podríamos decir el carbono tiene 4
electrones de valencia en su nivel de
energía
ahora también tengo que buscar el
hidrógeno en esta tabla periódica pues
está por aquí y como podemos ver está en
el grupo 1 y eso nos dice que el
hidrógeno tiene exactamente un electrón
de valencia entonces podemos poner a un
hidrógeno por aquí con su electrón de
valencia y podemos poner el segundo
hidrógeno con su elección de valencia y
otro hidrógeno y otro hidrógeno con su
electrón de valencia aunque ya tenemos
cuatro hidrógenos como en la fórmula y
entonces puedo empezar a conectar mis
puntos sabemos que dos electrones de
valencia de dos átomos distintos forman
un enlace covalente simple entonces
estos dos electrones forman un enlace
con lente simple estos también al igual
que estos y estos y listo ya tenemos la
estructura de puntos de lewis del metano
completa
también podemos ver que este carbono
está rodeado por 8 electrones de
valencia
aquí tenemos 2 electrones de valencia
más 24 aquí con estos 6 y 8 y el hecho
de que haya 8 electrones rodeando al
carbono hace que este carbono sea muy
estable
gray si nos fijamos en la tabla
periódica podemos ver por qué tenemos
que fijarnos en el segundo periodo que
es el segundo renglón de esta tabla y
podemos ver aquí que el carbono está por
acá y que tiene 4 electrones de valencia
aquí este tiene un electrón de valencia
dos electrones de valencia 3 electrones
de valencia 4 electrones de valencia y
pues nos podemos seguir este tiene 5
electrones de valencia 6 electrones de
valencia 7 electrones de valencia y 8
electrones de valencia entonces cuando
estos hidrógenos hacen enlaces
covalentes con el carbono 8 electrones
empiezan a girar alrededor
el carbono y entonces pareciera que este
carbono tiene la configuración
electrónica de este gas noble y bueno
resulta que los gases nobles son muy
estables porque todos sus orbitales en
este nivel de energía están llenos así
es que si hay 8 electrones de valencia
girando alrededor del carbono aunque
algunos de estos electrones en realidad
pertenecían al hidrógeno estamos
llenando todos los orbitales del carbono
así es que el máximo número de
electrones que pueden rodear al carbono
es 8 ahora vamos con el hidrógeno el
hidrógeno está en este primer periodo o
sea en el primer renglón que además es
el primer nivel de energía y pues aquí
el hidrógeno tiene un electrón de
valencia y en este otro renglón está el
helio con 2 electrones de valencia en el
primer nivel de energía solo se puede
encontrar al orbital ese y en él sólo
caben 2 electrones entonces si llenamos
el orbital
con dos electrones llegamos a la
configuración de este gas noble y
entonces el hidrógeno es estable cuando
hay dos electrones girando a su
alrededor lo cual tiene sentido no sea
porque con dos electrones llenamos el
único orbital que tiene el hidrógeno que
es el orbital
s - pero veamos otras estructuras de
puntos pero pues vamos a hacer una que
tenga nitrógeno entonces pues vamos a
hacer ch3
eine h 2
entonces puede empezar por mi carbono le
pongo sus 4 electrones de valencia a sus
lados y ahora tengo h 3 que sabemos que
los podemos poner por aquí con su
electrón de valencia
todos estos hidrógenos y ahora pues hay
que buscar al nitrógeno en esta tabla
periódica y pues está por aquí y como
podemos ver tiene 5 electrones de
valencia
entonces ponemos aquí el nitrógeno y
podemos representar esos 5 electrones de
valencia de esta forma poniendo el
quinto por acá ahora todavía nos faltan
estos dos hidrógenos pero pues aquí el
nitrógeno tiene unos electrones de
valencia que se van a llevar muy bien
con los electrones del hidrógeno y ahora
si puedo conectar todos los puntos que
están formando los enlaces covalentes
simples
y también podemos verificar la regla del
octeto tenemos aquí al carbono y tiene a
ver tiene 2 468 electrones girando a su
alrededor y del nitrógeno pues el
nitrógeno está por aquí o sea que está
en el segundo nivel de energía así es
que su gas noble más cercano tiene 8
electrones de valencia así es que el
nitrógeno también es estable si tiene 8
electrones y dando su alrededor
así es que pues vamos a contarlos jay 1
2 4 6 8 bueno entonces vamos a hacer
otro ejemplo ahora hay que ver uno que
tenga un oxígeno por ejemplo el metanol
el metanol es
h 3 o h
entonces podemos empezar con nuestro
carbono que sabemos que tienen 4
electrones de valencia
4 y luego están 3 hidrógenos con sus
correspondientes electrones de valencia
que los podemos dibujar por aquí y ahora
vamos a dibujar un oxígeno entonces
vamos a la tabla y vemos que lo exige no
está en el grupo 6 de nuestra tabla y
eso significa que tiene 6 electrones de
valencia
entonces ponemos por aquí en nuestro
oxígeno y le tenemos que poner 6
electrones de valencia aquí llevamos 4
entonces tenemos que escoger alguno de
estos cuatro lugares para poner otros
dos puntitos y ahora si ya tiene 6
electrones de valencia a su alrededor
pero pues todavía nos falta poner este
hidrógeno y pues vemos que aquí hay un
muy buen lugar para ponerlo porque aquí
hay un solo punto solito en el oxígeno y
ahora si empezamos a unir los puntos que
están formando los enlaces entre estos
átomos vemos que aquí el carbono tiene
un enlace con el oxígeno y después este
oxígeno tiene un enlace con este
hidrógeno
única forma en la que podíamos haber
acomodado estos átomos y además el
oxígeno está en el segundo nivel su gas
noble más cercano tiene 8 electrones de
valencia entonces está estable si tiene
8 electrones a su alrededor y podemos
ver aquí tiene 1 2 3 4 este enlace
simple lo conforman dos electrones
entonces aquí tenemos 6 electrones y 8
electrones así es que hay 8 electrones
girando alrededor del oxígeno y también
hay 8 electrones girando alrededor del
carbono tenemos 2 468 electrones ahora
vamos a ver el etano
el eterno es 02 h 6 y bueno cuando
estamos dibujando la estructura de
puntos de louis de una fórmula molecular
no siempre tenemos que hacerlo como lo
estábamos haciendo cuando dibujamos cada
átomo con sus puntos y luego los unimos
aunque podemos empezar por dibujar de
una vez la estructura que creemos que va
a tener o si aquí tenemos dos carbonos y
es una muy buena apuesta decir que esos
dos carbonos van a estar enlazados y una
vez que ya tenemos estos dos carbonos
enlazados pues tenemos seis hidrógenos y
lo más natural sería que hubiera tres
hidrógenos en cada carbono que tenemos
ahí nuestros
hidrógenos enlazados con un enlace
simple
y luego una vez que dibujamos nuestra
estructura pues hay que fijarnos y si
cumple con la regla del octeto bueno y
otra cosa que también tenemos que
verificar es que no nos están faltando
puntitos y para eso pues vemos a ver el
carbono tiene cuatro electrones de
valencia y tenemos dos de esos carbonos
entonces los carbonos aportan ocho
electrones de valencia y por otro lado
los hidrógenos cada hidrógeno aporta un
electrón de valencia tenemos seis
hidrógenos entonces esos son otros seis
electrones de valencia en total ocho
unas seis son 14 tenemos que ver que en
esta estructura haya 14 electrones de
valencia y hay 1234567 enlaces
covalentes simples y cada enlace
covalente simple tiene 2 electrones de
valencia ya que tenemos 7 por 2 14
electrones de valencia dibujados así es
que pues esta estructura está muy bien
pues está así es la estructura de
de louis del etano